more than 50 million Americans face the
threat of severe weather today a
destructive system brought flooding
overnight to parts of Louisiana winds
approaching 100 miles an hour ripped
apart homes in Texas tornado smashed
houses and broke the trees there the
risk of tornadoes continues today radar
shows the scope of the violent system
today severe weather threat stretches
from the Gulf Coast into Michigan David
beg no is in Oakdale Louisiana with a
new damage overnight David good morning
Gail good morning we've been on the road
since 2am tracking the severe weather
and it has led us here to Oakdale we
just talked to the mayor who believes it
was a tornado that moved through here
some of the damage is behind me but I
want to give you this look I'm always
amazed when a six foot one guy like
myself can stand in what was the root of
the tree and give me the impression of
what it looks like now I mean it
swallows a guy can you imagine the winds
that it would have taken to lay this bad
boy over about two and a half hours ago
this is a part of the same weather
system that we've been tracking since
Tuesday that started in Lubbock Texas
and is marching eastward overnight
severe storms swept through the South
more than 9 inches of rain caused flash
flooding in southern Louisiana while
high winds brought down trees and
damaged buildings at least one tornado
was reported near Hector Arkansas that's
about 60 miles northwest of little rock
in Fort Worth Texas last night two young
boys were electrocuted by downed power
lines in a wooded area officials think
the lines were brought down by
Wednesday's severe weather we can't talk
about enough need for
safety around down power lines we're
just starting to storm season this is
something we'll continue to deal with in
Houston Wednesday afternoon drivers
brave floodwater the storm toppled
shipping containers at the Port of
Houston earlier in the day an ef-1
tornado caused extensive damage with
winds of up to 90 miles per hour at
least 18 tornadoes have been reported in
Texas this week one blew through this
Dallas suburb tearing apart homes and
snapping trees in nearby rockwall
straight-line winds of up to 95 miles
per hour battered this neighborhood I'm
in shock and it it's horrible inside
horrible pieces of wood mattresses and
insulation were ripped from the homes
one man was hurt when he was thrown from
his bedroom onto his lawn Jerry
Harwood's house was spared despite some
damage I think probably the damage that
we have on our house is from all the
debris and everything that came from the
other three homes that you're seeing
parts of eight different states are
facing the possibility of seeing a
tornado today from Ohio to Mississippi
heads up you could have severe weather
in your area Charlie we have confirmed
that in the nashville tennessee area the
metro area they've actually canceled
school today as a precaution David thank
you so much